one of the most vindictive and power
hungry coveted tyrants
suddenly reversed his stance on shutting
down businesses
we simply cannot stay closed
until the vaccine hits critical mass the
cost is too high
we will have nothing left to open
wait a second isn't that what we've been
saying since i don't know last may
you're going to destroy your city and
state days after cuomo is about faith
chicago mayor lori lightfoot
made the exact same announcement
i want to get our restaurants and our
bars reopen as quickly
as possible they've gone above and
beyond to put in mitigation controls
inside of the restaurants they are going
to be one of the safer places
wait a second i think we were criticized
for saying that exact same thing
by all the fancy people in the media how
weird is this change of heart
and it's coming right before biden comes
into office joining me now phil kerpin
president of the committee to unleash
prosperity phil you and i
on this show i don't know how many times
we talked about this the restaurants
aren't spreading the virus the schools
aren't spreading the virus
open up wash your hands and use some
common sense
now they're suddenly sounding like us
what's going on
yeah it's amazing uh there was another
one today ralph northam today said we
know schools are safe we need to open
the screen
basically everyone who we've been
fighting
for the last year for what seems like
forever laura on this stuff
uh suddenly they're saying the same
things we've been saying all along and
saying oh well no actually
we need to open things up and honestly i
can't see a single thing that has
changed
uh other than the political context well
joe biden
uh comes in and he has a 100-day mass
mandate
that was that was a big part of it he
said there are going to be a hundred
million
i don't know his obsession with the
hundred thing but a hundred days
a hundred million it's kind of his
branding thing why not 125 million i
don't know
100 million vaccine doses is there any
sense that
they're really going to be able to do it
any better than
has been done already isn't it isn't it
skepticism
from some quarters including health care
workers about the vaccine itself
well look the vaccine rollout is not
going nearly as well as it should be
especially in some
very big very liberal states like new
york and california that have been total
disasters
on vaccine rollout it's going a lot
better in places like florida and texas
and
remarkably the best state for vaccine
rollout is west virginia which i don't
think a lot of coastal elites would have
predicted
but they've vaccinated every nursing
home resident in the state of west
virginia and they've already done over
12 percent
of all the seniors in the state of west
virginia and they did that laura
by opting out of the federal program
they did not use cvs and walgreens in
the federal program instead
they used all of their local pharmacies
all of the independent pharmacies and
they were able to assign
a pharmacy to each nursing home in the
federal program each cvs in walgreens
has about 25
nursing homes and that's why it's been
so slow to roll out and so i think
the problem is we have too much federal
involvement federal leadership
bureaucracy not too little and i really
worry that biden's going to layer even
more on
now biden also announced he's going to
help the economy recovered from coveted
lockdowns this way
should be a national minimum wage of 15
an hour
no one working 40 hours a week should
live
below the poverty line that's what it
means if you work
for less than 15 an hour and work 40
hours a week you're living in poverty
uh small businesses are trying to dig
out of a recession
is this going to work uh first of all
that's plainly false what he just said
because of the earned income credit and
the child tax credit
anyone at the current minimum wage for
any family structure is above the
poverty line and you can run the math on
that you can check that
so it is not true that anyone who works
full-time is below the poverty line in
this country
already but of course you know the vast
majority of minimum wage workers
are teenagers or young people who have
very limited work experience
and want to get that first rung on the
economic ladder and when you essentially
say
it's illegal for you to work if your
work is not worth 15
an hour or more you're pricing a lot of
people out of the labor force people who
need that early work experience
so they can move up that ladder and have
more opportunities down the line and so
i think this is of a piece with his
expanded unemployment bonuses paying
people
not to work and it is going to be
devastating as as you uh pointed out
there
for businesses that are trying to get
back off the floor from being locked
down and shut down
if they do have a need for entry-level
workers but it won't cost anything right
phil for illegal immigrants to get
obamacare which they're going to get
under the biden plan as well
they get obamacare they get all others i
mean it's all free phil thanks so much
the